yeah welcome to this video playing home
team hmm it's the white side the home
team actually hmm maybe but Jesse's got
black him okay the bogo he's playing the
ball William hmm okay yeah the Queen e7
line not a bad line at all yes I just
play very simple here not doing anything
anything fancy it's not really a triad
ref as the refutation which is not
possible anyway but want to play simple
and quick for once
try to gain some space it's not so easy
from black with his slide disadvantage
in space to play Knight d4 Bishop a 3-1
idea okay he's just doing this hmm I can
go to f5
yeah that's all fairly standard the kind
of the type of position and the type of
play um Quincy to Bishop f3 it's got a
five which is a bit bit annoying yeah
maybe I made some kind of in precise
move it's not not not bad or anything
but it seems that should have gotten a
little bit more out of it not much but a
little bit more okay III before is what
I want to do yeah I was recognizing this
the thought hmm is this a problem f 5m
yeah black is definitely okay it's got
various um decent ideas here my pieces
are not really well coordinated I'm not
sure that that you should play something
like f5 I think this is not a good
timing for that this is a good move just
improving this this piece a bit hmm so
let's see maybe I can get rid of the
Queen ham
I still wonder ff5 is a move but Smith I
think I can take and this is not really
that great ok I have no checked again
the queen is his queen is not protected
this is why I'm thinking about a tactic
at all this may be it takes 92 hmm that
I'm not not really sure about I get
Queen deform this Bishop is a bit off
side on age 3 it's not clear that this
has helped him complicated position
angling for Queen d4 Knight is really
nice only three
yeah and what I'm trying to do is to
prove that this Bishop is a problem on
age three it's not really participating
in two in the game the best that it can
do is play Bishop g4 at some moment
trying to favorably trade itself a 3 B
form is of course the the general plan
that you have but I don't see how to get
it in just try to improve the the
coordination a little bit and maybe I
can play three before
hmm yeah yeah he's got the 3m if i take
that but only if i take it with the
bishop and I can take it with annoyed
actually and now use the King here as a
block ada
where are you going with your night
oh interesting interesting play ok I
have to do that anyway check and now
King d4
not quite sure what to do what what what
is precise iam I didn't think about high
morale at all and it's bad
let's play this really well defending
really nicely
that's not working yeah that result it's
not working huh that's it's kind of
weird what did I do wrong I mean here
I've ever have a total control this must
be very nice let's check I went here
that would be fire maybe I have to take
I mean maybe I have check at least I'm
invading here it's a pretty substantial
advantage but check him I mean I don't
know I simply rejected to take but this
was wrong am have to take yeah yeah just
take you for all right yeah with a very
nice game for wide check now this is
this as the weakness is the big problem
yeah but this this wasn't really i still
can take and i simply i simply fail to
recognize that the capture is is
something and TI well rook age seven or
something is just totally okay for him
again yeah this is this is just just
blundering blundering the house wow ok i
could have taken be five ton of times
but never never really realized that it
is much better okay if hope you enjoyed
it thanks for watching